herzlich willkommen zu einem Sommer re
Upload von Tatort Deutschland hier sind
Toni und Stefan yes wir präsentieren
euch heute zwei spannende historische
Fälle man sagt zwar Prostitution sei das
älteste Gewerbe der Welt aber ich glaube
mittlerweile die Mord Ermittlung ist
noch älter ich habe vorhin geguckt
allein in der Bibel gibt es
184 Morde angefangen von Kain und Abel
bis zum tödlichen Verrat an Jesus heute
gibt es als Sommerspecial zwei alte
Schinken für euch ja und ihr hört jetzt
gleich wie der Überflieger Julius Cäsar
völlig verpeilt hat dass er in
Lebensgefahr schwebt und im gleichen wie
Upload einen Krimi aus der Steinzeit
hallo mein Name ist Sky Demo und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
moin mein Name ist Natalie Strauß ich
bin Radiomoderatorin und damit
normalerweise im Hier und Jetzt
verhaftet doch heute nimmt Sprecher und
Moderatoren Mirko Kasimir und ich euch
mit auf einer Reise in die Vergangenheit
mehr als 2000 Jahre geht es heute zurück
und zwar ins Jahr 44 vor Christus in die
Eden des März und den Schauplatz des
wahrscheinlich berühmtesten politischen
Attentats vielleicht abgesehen vom Mord
an John F Kennedy ja es geht um den Mord
an Gajus Julius Caesar moin Mirko hallo
Natalie und du hast recht der Fall
Julius Caesar das ist ein richtiger
Klopper da gibt's zum einen natürlich
die Geschichte die Story an sich und die
die hat schon alles was ein Bestseller
oder Blockbuster braucht eine
Verschwörung verharrt wie alle kennen
den Namen Brutus eine Falle und düsterer
Omen und auch eine hallo die darf
natürlich auch nicht fehlen und das ist
eine der berühm diesen Affären der
Geschichte Caesar und Kleopatra okay das
hat jetzt nicht mit dem Mord zu tun aber
hat auf jeden Fall auch ihren Anteil auf
dem Weg dahin auf jeden Fall dann ist da
die historische Dimension dieses Falles
der Aufstieg und Fall Cäsars markiert
das Ende der römischen Republik und dem
Beginn des römischen Reiches und damit
kommen wir zu einer dritten Dimension
der Frage welche Lehren wir vielleicht
aus den Ereignissen damals ziehen können
wie wird aus einer Republik mit Macht
und Gewaltenteilung eine monokratie ein
Staat in dem alle Macht von einer Person
ausgeht
da ist auf jeden Fall einiges los wir
uns sicherlich die meisten Hörer und
Hörerinnen sind keine geschichtsexperten
deshalb Mirko einmal ganz kurzes Update
bitte was war da gleich noch mal los
damals in Rom
ich erzähl's mal am besten anhand der
Lebensgeschichte von Julius Gaius Cäsar
er wurde am 13 Juli des Jahres 100 vor
US geboren kleiner hat Notiz der Juli
hieß damals nicht juli sondern Quintiles
erst in Caesars Todesjahr 44 vor
Christus wurde sein Geburtsmonat ihn zu
ehren in Julius umbenannt
Caesar entstammte dem Patricia
Geschlecht der Julia die Abstammung bis
auf die Göttin Venus zurückführten als
junger Mann geriet Caesar in Konflikt
mit Lucius Cornelius Zula der damals als
Diktator über Rom herrschte
Caesar musste die Stadt verlassen und
machte Karriere in der Armee
das Wort Diktator das müssen wir
übrigens ganz kurz erklären dass wir
unsere Geschichte ziemlich wichtig ist
und damals eine etwas andere Bedeutung
hatte also in Kriegs und Krisenzeiten
ernannte man in der Republik einen
Diktator diesen wurde dann praktisch die
Alleinherrschaft übertragen das
besondere daran ist aber seine Ernennung
war zeitlich begrenzt auf maximal sechs
Monate auf keinen Fall sollte sich auf
seiner Diktatur dann auch eine
dauerhafte Herrschaft entwickeln
500 Jahre zuvor war der letzte römische
König davon gejagt und die Republik
wurde errichtet die Abneigung gegen die
Monarchie war also fest verwurzelt sola
war der erste der versuchte diese
aufzuweichen und seine Amtszeit als
Diktator zu verlängern er trat aber auch
schließlich freiwillig zurück so wie
alle anderen Diktatoren vor ihm leider
ist das so ein bisschen aus der Mode
geraten ja unter den aktuellen
Diktatoren das können wir mal wieder
einführen aber Mirko erzählt du erstmal
wieder weiter
78 vor Christus nach soll das Abdankung
als Diktator begann Caesars politische
Karriere in Rom und erregte schnell
Aufsehen und die Aufmerksamkeit
mächtiger Feinde die politische Klasse
war damals tief gespalten auf der einen
Seite standen die popularis denen sich
Caesar zugehörig fühlte und die sich auf
die Volksversammlung stützten sei es aus
politischen Kalkül man würde sie heute
wohl Populisten nennen oder aus echtem
Interesse an den Belangen des Volkes auf
der anderen Seite die Optimaten die
Vertreter des konservativen Adels zu
denen auch Zulage gehörte
um der Feindschaft zulass aus dem Weg zu
gehen verließ Caesar Rom erneut und
begab sich auf eine Studienreise nach
Rhodos
da ist allerdings nie angekommen weil er
unterwegs und Piraten gekippt ne wurde
die wiederum ein Lösegeld für seine
Freilassung verlangten Caesar war
darüber richtig wütend wie man sich
natürlich vorstellen kann allerdings
nicht aus offensichtlichen Gründen was
ihn besonders wütend machte war nicht
die Tatsache an sich sondern dass sie
Piraten wohl zu wenig Lösegeld forderten
er war der Meinung er sei deutlich mehr
wert und hat die Piraten dann
tatsächlich überzeugt die Sonne
herauszusetzen so hat das zumindest
selber später berichtet
nach seiner Freilassung organisierte er
eine private Seestreitmacht jagte und
fing die Piraten ein und ließ sie
allesamt kreuzigen
Caesar kehrte erneut nach Rom zurück
setzte seine politische Laufbahn fort
und wurde schließlich in den Senat
aufgenommen und das Jahr 67 vor Christus
heiratete er seine Frau pompeia eine
Enkelin ausgerechnet seines alten
Feindes zu LAH die Ehe hielt nur ein
paar Jahre
im Jahr 62 vor Christus erschütterte
einen Riesenskandal die römische
Republik in dem es um die
Fruchtbarkeitsgöttin Bohner der einen
Mann in Frauenkleidern und entweite
Kultobjekte ging lange Geschichte im
Zuge dessen kamen Gerüchte auf pompea
hätte ein Verhältnis mit eben jenem Mann
und Frauenkleidern Publius Clodius
pulcher gehabt und Caesar trennte sich
von mir nicht weil er an die Affäre
glaubte sondern so sagte er es Caesars
Frau muss frei von jedem Verdacht sein
boah bitte was ist das denn bitte für
eine Logik oh ich muss dich leider
verlassen weil andere schlecht über dich
denken könnten
tja
Caesar wurde Statthalter in Spanien wo
er große militärische Erfolge gegen die
Aufständischen lusitaner erringen konnte
er kehrte nach Rom zurück und bewarb
sich für das Amt eines konsols das
Konsulat war übrigens das höchste
römische Amt die Konsulen standen dem
Senat vor und waren die militärischen
Oberbefehlshaber da gab es dann auch
strenge Regeln um zu verhindern dass
sich aus dem Konsulat eine
Alleinherrschaft oder Gott bewahre sogar
eine Monarchie entwickeln konnte somit
war die Amtszeit auf ein Jahr begrenzt
und es gab immer zwei Konsolen um sich
die Macht zu teilen aber Mirko ich
glaube wir müssen den kleinen Zahn
zulegen oder klar machen wir 59 vor
Christus wurde Caesar endlich zum
konsulberufen und begann die römische
Politik umzukrempeln
er überschritt seine Befugnisse hielt
sich nicht an Regeln machte sich aber
mit Brot und Spielen beim Volk extrem
beliebt
[Musik]
nach einem Jahr als Konsul ginge als
Stadthalter nach Gallien eroberte
riesige Gebiete drang bis ans rechte
reinufer und nach Britannien vor im Jahr
50 vor Christus kehrte er nach Italien
zurück sein Ziel war es seine ungeheure
Popularität im Volk zu nutzen um sich
erneut zum Konsul wählen zu lassen
seine Gegner wollten das um jeden Preis
verhindern und ihn vor Gericht stellen
sie forderten ihn auf die Waffen
niederzulegen und das Kommando über
seine Legionen abzugeben
keine Option für Caesar am 10 Januar 49
vor Christus überschritten Caesar und
seine treu ergebene 13 Legion den
Rubikon
die Würfel waren gefallen die bewaffnete
Überquerung dieses Grenzflusses zwischen
den Nordprovinzen und dem eigentlichen
Italien war eine Kriegserklärung gegen
den römischen Senat es kam zu einem
langen blutigen Bürgerkrieg aus dem
Caesar dann schließlich als Sieger
hervorging seinen er petterten fein
popeus verfolgte er dann sogar bis nach
Alexandria wo er wiederum Bekanntschaft
von Kleopatra machte und die legendäre
Affäre der beiden begann
nach seiner Rückkehr nach Rom
ähm ich habe den Eindruck dass ich
diesen Satz heute schon ein paar mal
gesagt habe
Caeser was für ein Hin und Her nach
seiner triumphalen Rückkehr nach Rom
wurde Caesar zum Diktator auf zehn Jahre
ernannt ein krasser Bruch mit allen
Traditionen der die Befürchtungen
wachsen ließ er wolle sich zum König
machen
im Februar 44 vor Christus ging er noch
einen Schritt weiter er ließ sich zum
Diktator perpeto zum Diktator auf
Lebenszeit nennen
außerdem ließ er sich einen goldenen
Thron aufstellen und seine Statue ins
pantium den Schrein der Götter
transportieren ein König um Himmels
willen ich doch nicht Gott passt schon
eher zu mir man kann also verstehen dass
das seine Gegner nicht wirklich
überzeugte und so begann eine Gruppe von
Verschwörern seine Ermordung zu planen
unter ihnen Markus Junius Brutus
Brutus gehörte zu Cäsars engstem
Freundeskreis für den Diktator war er
beinahe wie ein Sohn oder war er
vielleicht sogar sein Sohn
Brutus Mutter Servilia war eine der
Geliebten Caesars gewesen auch zeitlich
passen diese Beziehung und Brutus Geburt
gut zusammen aber sei es wie es sei
Caesar war Brutus ein väterlicher Freund
und vertraute ihm
Brutus selbst führt seine Abstammung auf
Lucius Julius Brutus zurück eine
legendäre Gestalt die der Sage nach im
Jahr 59 vor Christus den letzten
römischen König vertrieben und die
Republik gegründet hatte
dieses Erbe bestärkte Brutus in seinem
Willen Caesars Herrschaft zu beenden und
so hoffte er die Republik zu retten
mehr als 60 Senatoren waren schließlich
in den Plan eingeweiht und der Plan war
einfach auf der letzten Szene hat
Sitzung vor seiner Abreise zu einem
neuen Feldzug sollte Caesar mit Dolchen
getötet werden da nur Senatorin Zugang
hatten und seine Leibwächter ihn daher
nicht würden schützen können wäre er den
Attentätern hilflos ausgeliefert
am Abend vor dem Attentat speiste Caesar
im Haus seines Freundes dieser fragte
ihn der Überlieferung zufolge welchen
Tod er für den besten halte
Caesar soll geantwortet haben der
unerwartete
am nächsten Tag sollte Caesar seinen
bevorzugten Tod sterben obwohl er nur
für ihn unerwartet kam und keinesfalls
unangekündigt
Caesar hatte zahllose Warnungen bekommen
ein sehr warnte ihn vor den Iden des
März
Ihnen das März noch so ein berühmter
Begriff wir benutzen den Begriff nur im
Plural aber eigentlich sind die jeden
nur einen Tag in jedem Monat entweder
der 13 oder der 15 die ihnen das März
meint den 15.03
etwas Schreckliches würde in den Iden
des März Geschehen er habe es in den
Eingeweiden gelesen und Caesar solle
sein Haus nicht verlassen seine Frau
kalt purnier die trotz seiner
öffentlichen Liebschaft zu Kleopatra
treu zu ihm stand hat in der Nacht
schreckliche Albträume und sah düsterer
Omen es heißt Caesar habe daraufhin
tatsächlich erwogen der Senatssitzung
fernzubleiben
man muss dazu wissen dass er ohnehin
nicht viel vom Sinn hat hielt und von
dem was am politischen Theater noch von
der Republik übrig war außerdem fühlte
er sich unwohl manchen Quellen zufolge
aufgrund eines Katers offenbar wurde
beim Essen und über den besten Tod reden
im Haus des Freundes wohl auch
ordentlichert
die Verschwörer schickten Brutus zu
Zähler und es gelang ihm davon zu
überzeugen doch teilzunehmen es heißt er
habe sich darüber lustig gemacht dass
Caesar etwas auf die düsteren Ahnungen
einer Frau gäbe und so machte sich ca
auf den Weg zum Theater des pompeus in
dem die Sitzung des Senats stattfinden
sollte unterwegs traf auf den Seher der
ihn vor den Iden des März gewarnt hatte
und sagte die ihnen des März sind da
da sind sie aber noch nicht vorbei
antwortete der düster
ebenfalls auf dem Weg zum Theater
erreichte Caesar eine Schriftrolle die
Details der Verschwörung enthielt
doch er übergab sie einen Mitglied
seines Stabes um sie dann später zu
lesen doch das mit dem später wurde
nichts mehr verzähler
seine letzte Chance verstrich direkt vor
dem Theater sein Freund Markus Antonius
hatte von den Attentatsplänen erfahren
und versuchte Caesar zu warnen doch die
Verschwörer konnten ihn aufhalten und
Caesar tappte in die Falle
das Theater ist gut gefüllt
600 Senatorin sind anwesend und die
meisten von ihnen sind ahnungslos
kurz nach dem Caesar den Senat betreten
hat tritt Senator tilius Zimmer an ihn
heran
vorgeblich um eine Petition zu
überreichen die die Verbannung seines
Bruders aufheben soll
Caesar winkt ihn ungeduldig Weg er hat
keine Zeit und keine Interesse doch
statt sich zurückzuziehen greift Zimba
nach Caesars Toga sieht sie herunter und
entblößt seine Schulter Caeser schreit
auf das ist der Gewalt
doch es ist nur der Auftakt zur Gewalt
der Startschuss für einen Mord das unter
den Verschwörern verabredete Zeichen sie
haben sich längst unauffällig um ihn
versammelt jetzt greifen Sie nach den
Dolchen die sie unter ihren Drogen
verborgen in das Theater geschmuggelt
haben den ersten Streich führt Senator
servilius kaska von hinten sticht der
Cäsar in den Nacken
der fährt herum greift den Arm des
Attentäters kaska du Schurke was tust du
ruft er so berichtet es später der
Geschichtsschreiber pro Tag und kaska
schreit um Hilfe im nächsten Augenblick
stechen sie alle auf ihn ein Cäsar
versucht zu entkommen doch er ist schon
schwer verletzt blind vom Blut das ihm
in die Augen sind er stolpert und fällt
bedeckt das Gesicht mit seiner Toga
während die Attentäter weiter auf ihn
einstechen
auch du Brutus sind seine letzten Worte
oder so ähnlich laut anderen Quellen
sagte er etwas in der Art von auch du
Kind was als Beleg für die These vom
Sohn genommen wird andere berichten aber
gar nichts mehr gesagt fest steht aber
tot sein Körper von 23 Messerstichen
getroffen
nach der Tat marschierten die Attentäter
zum Capitol und riefen Volk von Rom wir
sind wieder frei
doch statt es erwarteten Jubels schlug
ihnen eisiges Schweigen entgegen
Caesars Beerdigung war ein letzter
großer Triumph über die Attentäter das
Volk von Rom betrauerte einen Helden die
ganze Sache geriet etwas außer Kontrolle
als immer mehr Menschen herantrinken und
das Feuer des Caesars Leichnam verzehren
sollte mit trockenen Zweigen Möbeln und
Kleidungsstücken füttern
Veteran in seiner Legionen warfen ihre
Waffen in die Flammen Frauen warfen
ihren Schmuck ins Feuer das Forum
Romanum wurde ernsthaft in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen
und die römische Republik war so tot wie
der Mann vor dem die Attentäter sie
retten wollte es folgte ein 13-Jähriger
Bürgerkrieg und an dessen Ende stand das
römische Reich unter der Herrschaft des
ersten Kaisers das ersten Cäsaren
Augustus
niemand kann sagen wie die Geschichte
ohne Caesars Ermordung verlaufen wäre
hätte er eines Tages doch noch sein Amt
niedergelegt und die verfassungsmäßige
Ordnung wiederhergestellt und
wahrscheinlich klar ist jedenfalls dass
die Verschwörer zwar ihr unmittelbares
Ziel das Ermordung erreichten ihr
eigentliches Ziel aber vollkommen
verfehlten spannend ist auch keiner von
Caesars Mördern überlebte ihn länger als
drei Jahre sie wurden von Caesar
Getreuen ermordet begingen Selbstmord
einige starben in Schlachten
der Tyrann ist tot Jesus später aber die
Tyrannei lebt
[Musik]
ja und damit sind wir fast am Ende
Mirko was macht die Geschichte mit dir
naja wir haben ja schon zu Anfang die
vielen Dimensionen dieses Falls
aufgezählt aber es ist wohl ein
politischer Mord wie es ihnen häufig in
der Geschichte gab doch heute noch es
ist wirklich erstaunlich wie diese ganze
Geschichte Nachhalt immerhin kennt jeder
der sich auch nur ein bisschen für
Geschichte interessiert die Namen Caesar
Brutus Kleopatra und jeder kennt die
Zitate den Rubikon überschreiten die
Würfel sind gefallen oder auch du Brutus
diese Geschichte steckt ganz tief im
Fundament der abendländischen Kultur und
dann ist er eben noch die Sache mit den
Lehrern die man daraus ziehen kann ne
oder eben halt nicht was mich da
beeindruckt ist diese ja fast schon
Naivität mit der die Verschwörer da
answerke gegangen sind wenn nur ca weg
ist dann ist sie Republik gerettet aber
so einfach ist das ja nicht es gibt ja
heute oft auch diesen Gedanken wenn nur
dieser oder Jena Autokrat Weg wäre dann
wäre das Problem gelöst aber solange die
Ursachen rechte Seite sind ist alles gar
nicht mal so einfach also ist glaube ich
die wichtigste Lektion es ist alles gar
nicht so einfach und Mord ist auch
überhaupt gar keine Lösung da gebe ich
dir auf jeden Fall recht Maut kann nie
eine Lösung sein ich glaube darauf
können wir uns auf jeden Fall einigen ja
liebe Podcast Hörerinnen und Hörer
vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit wir
hoffen es hat euch gefallen und ihr seid
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei
bei Tatort Deutschland Spezial macht's
gut und immer dran denken auf die eigene
Frau hören kann Leben retten
und eure Natalie
für unsere Schilderung dieser antiken
Geschichte haben wir unter anderem einen
Artikel der Welt eine Ausgabe der
ZDF-Reihe Terra x sowie die Portale das
römische Reich und wissen.de genutzt
außerdem wie er Wikipedia das
Schriftstück von Dan Calin Hardcore
history destrows of the Republic series
sowie den Podcast von Mike danke the
history of Rome
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Produktion Marvin schwarz
soweit alle Cäsar und seinen
schreckliches Ende jetzt gehen wir in
der Zeit vom alten Rom noch mal mehr als
3000 Jahre zurück da passiert einen Mord
der zu den ältesten Code cases überhaupt
gehört und cold gilt hier im
Gletschereis tatsächlich im Wortsinne
der Witz musste sein tut mir leid
Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschland Spezial mein Name ist
und ich wünsche euch eine spannende
Krimi Zeit
hello und hier ist wie immer eure
Natalie Strauß moin und euer Mirko
Casimir ähm Natalie sag mal kennst du
den Fall wo ein sportlicher mit 40er bei
einer Wanderung in den Südtiroler Alpen
hinterrücks mit einer Jagdwaffe ermordet
wurde
meinst du etwa den tätowierten
vollbartträger mit den Öko Klamotten und
der survival Ausrüstung genau der Typ
der selbst im Frühsommer nichts besseres
zu tun hatte als auf über 3000 m Höhe im
eisigen Wind und Schnee herum zu
spazieren das übliche Haltner ja klar
kenne ich den Fall liegt aber schon eine
Weile zurück
der Wanderer stemmt sich gegen den Wind
seit der über die Baumgrenze hinausgegen
ist bietet nichts dem wilden Getöse mehr
Einhalt er sagt sich zwar immer dass es
im Winter schlimmer wäre aber so richtig
glücklich ist er nun nicht mehr mit
seiner Entscheidung heute noch so Hals
über Kopf aufgebrochen zu sein
es ist nicht mehr weit er muss nur noch
über den kam dahinten gehen das wird der
schaffen bis Sonnenuntergang und dann
ist auch schon wieder der Abstieg dann
kommen wieder die schützenden Bäume und
es wird wärmer sein er rückt seine
kratze auf dem Rücken zurecht und die
Fellmütze tiefer über die Ohren
okay dann mal weiter
der Wanderer stöhnt ab und zu auf die
Knie tun ihm verdammt weh die Arthritis
schlägt in letzter Zeit immer heftiger
zu dann kommt noch der Druck in der
Brust oben drauf sein Herz wo man
ja das ist die Arteriosklerose von der
recht einseitigen Ernährung und zu guter
letzt noch das tiefe Husten gerade beim
Aufstieg von seinem ständigen
herumhängen im Rauch zu Hause
der Wanderer dreht sich abrupt um
irgendetwas stimmt nicht seit er mit
seinem zügigen Aufstieg aus dem Ort im
Tal begann hat er das Gefühl verfolgt zu
werden
vielleicht einer der jüngeren Typen aus
dem Ort vielleicht sogar der welcher ihn
gestern abend erst angeschrien und dann
mit dem Messer bedroht und verletzt hat
er schaut auf seine Hand die Wunde sieht
so weit okay aus das wird schon wieder
das schlimme ist eher der Junge Typ hat
seine Position als Chef im Ort in Frage
gestellt
dabei ist der einsame Wanderer der
erfahrenste unter den Bewohnern der
sagen wir mal Öko Kommune aber eben auch
schon recht alt sein lässiger baut und
die coolen langen Haare der
Waschbrettbauch und die Tattoos täuschen
nicht darüber hinweg sein Gesicht zeigt
die vielen Sommer im Hochgebirge in
jeder Falte
was soll's er verschwindet jetzt mal für
eine Weile ins Nachbar Tal woanders den
Sommer verbringen und den Hobbys fröhnen
hört sich eigentlich nicht schlecht an
also der Wanderer ist ganz allein auf
der Grenze zwischen Österreich und
Südtirol unterwegs
auf 3.200 Metern Höhe ist ein sehr
dicker Gletscher die Temperatur dort
deutlich unter dem Gefrierpunkt und das
schneit es stürmt ja also der Typ ist
quasi so eine Art Reinhold Messner nur
so ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen
und mit so einigen zipperleihen aber
sonst nichts weiter trotz seines Alters
sucht er aber immer noch Stress mit den
jüngeren die Frage ist jetzt nur woran
ging es denn jetzt eigentlich vielleicht
so ein typisches Männerding ja um Frauen
oder irgend so eine andere Rivalität die
sie da miteinander austragen mussten
irgendwas politisches aus der Kommune
vielleicht man weiß es nicht der
Wanderer hat bisher keine Namen schlecht
weil wir ihn nicht kennen
in dem kleinen Ort im Tal aus dem er
kommt Leben nicht viele Leute lassen wir
es vielleicht 100 Personen sein die
Berghütten in denen gelebt wird sind
recht geräumig und so leben dort alle
mit allen zusammen eigentlich ganz
gemütlich man ist strenge ökologisch
unterwegs Klamotten werden meist selbst
hergestellt und man setzt auf
Eigenversorgung etwas Landwirtschaft ein
paar Haustiere der Fischfang und die
Jagd sind auch genehmigt räumlich und
vor allem zeitlich liegt das Dorf etwas
ab vom Schuss es gibt noch lange kein
Telefon oder Strom hier
im Prinzip ist man in der Kommune soweit
glücklich und kommt gut zurecht
aber Streit gibt es dennoch immer wieder
die jungen wollen es auch mal zu was
bringen und die älteren wie unser
Wanderer stehende Sache im Wege dazu
bestimmen die alten Wehr mit wem
zusammen ist und vieles mehr außerdem
hat man sich im Ort aus so special
skills spezialisiert also sie stellen
eigene kupferwerkzeuge her unfassbar
wertvoll sind die Dinger weil es
natürlich Handarbeit alles Einzelstücke
und hier nicht wie bei uns made in China
und man ist auch im Waffengeschäft
involviert man hat sich spezialisiert
auf hochleistungslang Bögen für eine
besonders lautlose Art der Jagd im Ort
ist es auch gar nicht mal so
ungefährlich weil faktisch jeder
bewaffnet ist und Polizei oder Gerichte
das kennt ihr keiner hier werden die
Dinge unter sich geklärt
da ist doch irgendwas der Wanderer
schaut sich erneut um aus dem Gletscher
und dem schneehagen immer wieder dunkle
Felsformationen hervor
weil er nicht deine Bewegung der
Wanderer ruft in die Richtung der Felsen
keine Antwort
naja die Steinböcke queren auch diesen
Kamm hier vielleicht war es eines der
Tiere eigentlich eine gute Beute aber
frisches Fleisch braucht er heute nicht
und sein selbstgebauter Langbogen ist
noch in Arbeit nachdem sein letzter
kaputt gegangen ist
okay dann halt ein schnelles Picknick
der Wanderer sucht sich eine
windgeschützte Felsnische Klasse hier
lässt es sich aushalten er hat alles
dabei um sich ein kleines Feuer zu
machen auf kratze und Mathe sitzt der
bequem
sehr gut das geräucherte Hirschfleisch
ist lecker und das Obst aus kleinen
Äpfeln und Bären rundet den Snack gut ab
eigentlich wäre eine Runde schlafen
jetzt gut aber er muss weiter es ist
auch viel zu kalt wer weiß wie das
Wetter wird
dann doch lieber weiter über den Kamm
der Wanderer rappelt sich auf dann hört
er wie Steine Poltern ins Rollen kommen
da ist doch wer
er lässt seine Ausrüstung liegen und
steigt zum Felsen hinauf um zu schauen
was da los ist der Unbekannte Wanderer
hat schon Recht wenn er vermutet dass er
verfolgt wird sei dazu zügig
aufgebrochen ist folgt die nämlich die
ganze Zeit schon sein junger rivala
seinbad ist noch schwarz und seine
Kniegelenke sind noch richtig gut geölt
ja nicht so wie die unseres unbekannten
Wanderers mit dem langen Leben in den
Bergen dem Jungen Rivalen reicht's aber
nicht wenn der Wanderer für den Sommer
die Kommune verlässt denn wenn er im
Herbst zurückkommen würde geht es wieder
Streit um alles und jedes und das muss
aufhören und da gibt's nur einen Weg der
Wanderer muss sterben aber niemand darf
erfahren der Wanderer klettert auf einen
Felsvorsprung und muss lauter rülpsen
hey man sollte einfach nicht sofort
loslaufen wenn man gegessen hat
der Sturm hat sich gelegt der Himmel ist
blau der kann weit in die Teller schauen
aber am Horizont ziehen graue Wolken auf
er muss weiter
und da sieht er ihn da ist sein junger
Rivale vom Abend der der ihm auch die
Hand verletzt hat also ist er ihm die
ganze Zeit gefolgt und steht nun nur
einen Steinwurf weit entfernt und mit
wütendem Blick vor ihm
was will der bloß der Wanderer ruft ihm
zu dass er sich verdrücken soll sonst
setze es was aber der Typ hebt nur
seinen Langbogen an spannt einen Pfeil
auf und zielt auf ihn sag mal spinnt der
Wanderer hat seine Ausrüstung leider
unterhalb des Felsens liegen auf dem
steht Mist
blitzschnell dreht er sich um und will
wieder hinabklettern doch dann zerreißt
ein Schmerz seine linke Schulter der
Junge Rivale des Wanderers fackelt nicht
lange und schießt mit einem Pfeil des
langen Bogens auf den Flüchtenden der
hat keine Chance der Pfeil ist schnell
und spitz er durchdringt die dicke
Pelzjacke die Haut und das Schulterblatt
das Wanders er zerfetzt zwei wichtige
Blutgefäße und bleibt dann hinter dem
Schlüsselbein stecken der Wanderer
stürzt uns sanft in die Tiefe genau auf
seine Lagerstelle breit mit dem
Brustkorb auf einen großen Stein und ist
unmittelbar bewusstlos der Junge Rivale
haftet dem stürzenden Wanderer hinterher
er sieht ihn auch gleich bei euch links
neben seinem Lagerplatz liegen der rührt
sich nicht langsam tritt der Rivale auf
den Wanderer zu
ruckartig sieht er ihm den Pfeil aus dem
Rücken wobei die Spitze abbricht
verdammt das wird später eine Spur ein
Indiz sein aber egal er hat keine Zeit
denn es wird bald dunkel der Rücken des
Wanderers hebt sich leicht lebt der Typ
etwa noch das kann doch nicht wahr sein
nun
elegant ist es nicht aber der Rivale
nimmt einen Stein er zögert kurz reißt
die Fellmütze vom Kopf des Wanderers und
schlägt kräftig zu
der Wanderer ist tot das mit dem Stein
hätte sich der Rivale sparen können denn
sein Opfer wäre innerlich so oder so
schnell verblutet der Rivale überlegt
noch kurz ob er ein Teil der wertvollen
Ausrüstung des Wanders mitnehmen soll
das ist einiges dabei was ziemlich teuer
ist und er auch eigentlich gut
gebrauchen kann aber jeder am Ort würde
die Sachen erkennen und damit wissen
dass er den nervigen alten um die Ecke
gebracht hat und das ist ja nicht so
förderlich am besten einfach alles so
lassen wie es ist denn so sieht's nach
einem Unfall aus wenn man nicht ganz so
genau hinschaut aber am Ende kommt
sowieso keiner mehr so schnell hier hoch
auf den Berg dann geht der Rivale zurück
in die Kommune ob der Wanderer wohl
vermisst wird ja das wissen wir nicht
denn dazu ist nichts bekannt
danach ist auch schon ziemlich lange her
um genau zu sein
5.300 Jahre
ihr wisst natürlich längst wer der
Wanderer ist heute hat er einen Namen
Ötzi was wie aus einem ZDF alpenkrimi
klingt ist vermutlich so oder so ähnlich
abgelaufen und bis heute ein Cold Case
und ein ganz schön langer kalter call
Case Ötzi lag mehr als 5000 Jahre in und
auf einem Gletscher Schneide ein
gefroren taute wieder auf und gefror
wieder und wurde so zu der perfekt
erhaltenen feucht Mumien das Einfrieren
und das Auftauen hat mir der trockenen
hochgebirgsluft dafür gesorgt dass der
Leichnam gut erhalten geblieben ist bis
er dann am 19 September 1991 entdeckt
wird und zwar von den beiden deutschen
Urlaubern Erika und Helmut Simon die
finden ihn während einer Bergtour im
Bereich des diesen Jungs im Schnalstal
auf
3210 m Höhe
die Simons melden dem Fund dem
Hüttenwerk der semiauenhütte der
wiederum die österreichische Polizei und
die italienischen Carabinieri
einschaltet erst geht man von einem
verunglückten Bergsteiger aus am
nächsten Tag macht man einen ersten
Versuch den leicht Namen zu bergen aber
es ist schwierig den Toten aus dem
eisfrei zu bekommen nur ein uralt
wirkendes geborgen witzigerweise kreuzen
zwei Tage später die beiden bekannten
Südtiroler Bergsteiger Hans Kammerlander
und Reinhold Messner auf Messner sieht
die ganze Angelegenheit vor Ort und eine
Skizze des Balls ich muss sofort klar
dass die Person hier schon ein paar
hundert Jahre länger liegen muss
vielleicht ein bisschen unterschätzt
würde ich sagen nach einer ziemlich
rustikalen Bergungsaktion mit
Hubschrauber und Polizeikräften wird
klar das eigentlich Historiker oder noch
besser Archäologen vielleicht auch
Mumien Spezialisten sich der ganzen
Sache annehmen sollten eine erste C4
Altersbestimmung ergibt dass der
Leichnam
5.300 Jahre alt ist und damit aus der
späten Steinzeit und beginnen den
Kupferzeit stammt einer Zeit also in der
die Menschen schon sesshaft waren
Handwerk Jagd und Handel betrieben und
vor allem erste Werkzeuge aus Kupfer
hergestellt haben wie das gefundene Beil
bestens zeigt
die ganze Sache mit dem Eismann geht
pressemäßig steil und um die Welt ein
Wiener Journalist verpasst der Mumie
wegen des am Fundort angrenzenden
Ötztals den Namen Ötzi damit hat die
Welt einen richtig gut erhaltenen
Vertreter ihrer steinzeitvorfahren
mitten in Europa es wird noch mehr bei
der genaueren Untersuchung der
Fundstelle gefunden ich zähl mal ein
paar Sachen auf ein noch nicht ganz
fertiger Langbogen ne Pfeilen ein Messer
mit Feuerstein Klinge dazu ein Gerät zum
Schärfen aus Beinen und Holz
Gamaschen oder Beinlinge aus Leder und
Fell Schuhe aus Fell Leder basteln recht
warm und stabil geschnürt
ein Lendenschutz aus Leder plusgürtel
ein dicker Pelzmantel und eine warme
beerenfellkappe ein birkenrinden
Behältnis für glühende Holzkohle zum
Feuermachen wie man später experimental
archäologischer rausbekommt Reste einer
kratze und Köcher für die Pfeile und
kleinere Utensilien für die Jagd als sie
war also sehr gut ausgerüstet und
bestimmt nicht zum ersten Mal in der
rauen hochalpine Gegend unterwegs mit
Sicherheit nicht Ötzi war erfahren aber
für die damalige Zeit schon recht alt
und physisch verbraucht die
Wissenschaftler schätzen die Person
Ötzis auf 45 bis 50 Jahre mit knapp
einem Meter 60 Körpergröße bei einem
sportlichen Gewicht von 50 Kilogramm die
forensisch medizinischen Untersuchungen
haben zudem ergeben dass Ötzi kaputte
Kniegelenk hatte verstopfte Arterien ein
ruiniertes Gebiss und laut verschiedener
Merkmale in Bezug auf Knochenbrüche und
Hautveränderungen ein recht stressiges
Leben mit einigen Entbehrungen
gelebt haben Menschen wie als sie damals
in mittelgroßen Gemeinschaften seppen
und Gruppen alle zusammen in festen
Häusern mit großen zentralen
Feuerstellen weshalb hört sie auch
ordentlich Ruß in der Lunge hatte aber
das hat wohl damals niemanden
interessiert
alle wurden mit geräuchertem Fleisch und
fischsaat auch wenn nicht gerade
Jagdsaison war Tiere wurden mit der
gefährlichsten Waffe damals gejagt mit
dem Langbogen selbst große Tiere konnte
man damit aus bis zu 30 Metern
Entfernung tödlich treffen die
Pfeilspitzen waren aus Feuerstein auch
Silex genannt unfassbar Schaf und sehr
leicht aber man goss und schmiedete auch
schon Kupfer was man aus Oberitalien
importierte daraus wurden Äxte zum
Baumfällen und Hiebwaffen hergestellt
vergleichbar ist der Wert einer solchen
Axt heute sicher mit einer voll
eingerichteten Werkstatt eines
Handwerkers also irgendwas im
sechsstelligen Bereich
Ötzi muss wohl habend und anerkannt
gewesen sein sonst hätte er so ein
Werkzeug nicht besessen vielleicht war
auch genau das sein Problem alter Mann
und wohlhabens dabei noch relativ fit
und nicht willens den Staffelstab oder
die Arzt weiterzugeben die Verletzungen
die man an Ötzis Körper bei den
Untersuchungen in den letzten
Jahrzehnten fand sprechen dafür dass er
öfter gekämpft haben muss Rippenbrüche
des Nasenbein gebrochen und dann noch
die frische Verletzung an der Hand die
eintrittswunde und die Pfeilspitze fand
man dann übrigens durch mikroskopische
Untersuchung der Mumie und durch Röntgen
und CT Aufnahmen und spätestens dann war
klar dass er sie eine Verbrechen zum
Opfer gefallen war naja und auch was den
Tatort betrifft da er alles noch wie
gerade verlassen herum lag und selbst
wertvolle Gegenstände zurückgelassen
worden spricht für die These dass der
Mord wissenschaftlich politisch und
persönlich motiviert war der oder die
Mörder wollten den Ötzi loswerden und
den nicht beklauen vielleicht war ja
auch Ötzi der Fiesling und hat sich in
der Dorfgemeinschaft was zu Schulden
kommen lassen vielleicht selbst jemanden
umgebracht und sich dabei die Hand
verletzt vielleicht ist der Mann im Eis
nicht grundlos gestorben aber es musste
dann ohne Aussehen Geschehen ganz
heimliche Leben reine Spekulation wie so
vieles an aber sehr spannend auf jeden
Fall
Ötzi gibt uns durch sein erhalten
geblieben sein einen tiefen Einblick in
die steinzeitliche Kultur der Region
seine Tätowierungen trug er
beispielsweise an Stellen die ihn
schmerzten vielleicht in der Hoffnung
die leiden dadurch zu lindern eine
Tätowierung war zum Beispiel auf
Brusthöhe und siehe da als sie hatte
Gallensteine sehr schmerzhaft und nicht
wegzubekommen jedenfalls damals nicht
genauso gab es Tattoos an anderen
Gliedmaßen der Mann hatte aufgrund
seines Alters so einige gesundheitliche
Baustellen und daher ging man auch eine
Zeit lang davon aus dass sie vielleicht
in einem Ritus geopfert wurde weil es an
der Zeit war
aber schießt man jemandem der freiwillig
stirbt in den Rücken wohl eher nicht die
These mit dem Mord aus Rache aus
Eifersucht oder einfach einer neuen
Rangordnung wegen ist vielleicht die
wahrscheinlichste und das lässt uns an
diesem Fall nicht los jede neue
Erkenntnis der Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerin zur Steinzeit kann
auch die Zusammenhänge um Ötzi neu
beleuchten und sie uns anders bewerten
lassen es ist ein Cold Case was den
Mörder betrifft aber ein ganz heißer
Fall für die Wissenschaft
das hast du sehr schön gesagt Mirko ich
finde es auch total faszinierend dass
man einen Jahrtausend Jahre alten Mord
allein daran erkennen und deuten kann
anhand der Dinge die das Opfer bzw die
Mumie bei sich getragen hat und der
Verletzung die man bis heute
rekonstruieren kann es ist der Wahnsinn
was alles rekonstruiert werden kann ich
meine man weiß sogar was er zuletzt
gegessen hat was er zum Frühstück zuvor
am Tage zu sich nahm man kann den Weg
skizzieren den er durch die Berge nahm
und sogar sein Ziel vermuten aber
ausgerüstet um weiter zu machen hatte
einen neuen Bogen in Arbeit hatte seine
Garderobe ausgebessert er wollte gehen
aber man wollte ihn nicht ziehen lassen
na ja man weiß es nicht aber die Zukunft
kann und wird mit Sicherheit immer
wieder Neues über die Vergangenheit
bringen und so lässt uns ein
Jahrtausende Jahre alter Fall bis heute
nicht los und gibt uns einen Einblick in
dein Leben vor unserer aller Zeit wir
danken euch fürs Zuhören ja und wir
freuen uns auch schon auf die nächste
Episode mit euch gemeinsam bis dahin
euer Mirko und eure Nation die
faszinierende Geschichte von Ötzi haben
wir mit Hilfe des Südtiroler Archäologie
Museums erzählt so wie das Portals der
Region Ötztal auf dessen Webseite
ötztal.com gibt es auch gute Tipps zum
Erkunden der Region in der die
Gletscherleiche gefunden wurde Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband und Antonia haya
Produktion serdarinis
das waren die Uploads für diese Woche
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst uns
das gerne wissen zum Beispiel mit einer
Mail an podcast@bild.de oder auch per
Instagram die Links dazu findet ihr wie
immer in den Show Notes also lasst uns
gerne wissen ob euch diese reploads
überhaupt so grundsätzlich gefallen oder
ob euch das eher nervt weil ihr schon
alle Folgen gehört habt oder alles was
euch dazu einfällt einfach her zu uns
nächste Woche hören wir uns dann wieder
da geht es um Zweifelsfälle der Justiz